the dreamville [ __ ] was so crazy has
there
any discussion of like doing it doing
the volume four in the future
for sure we got to do that i feel like
three kind of
you know opened a lot of people's eyes
to because the first two were super
slept on
yeah very much so yeah but you know
everything happens for a reason and you
know within its timing i feel like
when three came around um we had a lot
of artists on the label that have
reached
just new levels on there for sure
whether it was myself
arijit irv gang who said kaz omen luke
um and then going back to what you said
about how cohesive it was i think that's
because we did it all in those
10 11 days that we were everybody was
together yeah everyone was together
it was like okay i'm walking into this
session all right
you guys already got like two verses in
the hook let me do a bridge
right or you know i'm walking into this
session all right you know you guys need
a hook
let me try this hook idea you know what
i mean
as opposed to like sending tracks back
and forth and trying to
put this piece it was just literally
like who's in the room who stumbled into
the room like
you know some of those tracks had like
eight people on them
that's real you feel me so all right
well just keep it to eight bars
he's laying on doing 16s on this um
it was a lot of that and it was cool to
see people just process you know artists
have
such a wide range of creative processes
like
some people don't want no one around and
then you'd see those people
like come out of that show yeah like
because they almost have no choice like
imagine being the guy that goes all the
way to atlanta
right i was like could everybody leave
yeah yeah yeah that wasn't gonna happen
right you know um so it was cool to see
people just
adapt to each other's creative process
nah i think it was it was done so i mean
volume four has got a
got to be i mean volume three it just
performs so well too
the grammy nom like such a big deal man